samedi matin il est aux alentours de 11
heures entre la rue ordener et la rue
custine c'est dans le xviiie
arrondissement de paris sont des rues
voilà je passe beaucoup de choses ça
bouge beaucoup un randonneur notamment
un équipage de police repère une voiture
dans laquelle il y a quatre individus
donc il y a deux garçons deux filles
c'est ça absolument donc il s'approche
alors du véhicule
donc là il s'approche du véhicule est là
qu est ce qui se passe alors dans un
premier temps je souhaite quand même au
nom de la famille que je représente de
la victime
est bien avoir une pensée pour elle
parce que rihanna avait 21 ans et j'ai
lu aujourd'hui dans la presse des
versions qui sont totalement
hallucinante car je tiens à préciser que
premièrement rayhana première on ne
connaissait pas le conducteur je crois
que c'est un point extrêmement important
à savoir elle ne connaissait pas
deuxièmement rihanna et c'est une jeune
fille qui n'avait pas de casier
judiciaire
parce que on a entendu de tout ça c'est
quand même important déjà parce que pour
la famille jackson souffrance mais
d'entendre des horreurs sur elle c'est
insupportable j'aimerais qu'on revienne
sur ce qu'on m'avait raconté ce matin
parce que elle se retrouve dans la
voiture deux garçons qu'elle connaît pas
exactement l'heure c'est quoi l'histoire
est bien l'histoire ça qu'on fait il
était un ardent un after c'est l'after
c'est que en fait elle est à 6 heures du
matin elle est appelée par sa copine
inez qu'il dit voilà on fait un after en
boîte est ce que tu venais les terralies
bien sûr je viens pas de soucis ou d'un
joint de copains et donc ils sont rendus
à cet after ils sont ils en boîte de
nuit et de 6h à 9h du matin il s'avère
qu'elle n'avait pas d'argent et plus
d'argent pour prendre un taxi way and
bear et du coup et bien un garçon ce
garçon arras et proposé de les ramener
chez elle d'accord le connaissais pas du
tout pas du tout d'accord c'est une
connaissance d'un mall cop un oeil elle
ne le connaissait pas donc elle va
acceptent ces choses que mais ça c'est
important ce soir mais c'est important
que c'est vous dire pourquoi ils savent
ce que ça peut arriver à vos enfants oui
ça
peut arriver à vos enfants à tous donc
tant attendue aujourd'hui est
extrêmement choquant alors donc sylvie
donc elle monte dans la voiture alors
qu'il monte dans la voiture elle montre
seulement tout elle elle monte à la
halle avant elle était pas ag avant et
donc il a une copine à qui mon talent à
rien sa copine est derrière elle c'est
ça et puis j'ai entendu effectivement
dans le son les ondes était de l'autre
côté et là dessus il ya un contrôle de
police parce que l'un d'eux n'avait pas
de ceinture de sécurité
dont contrôle de police et tué et le
conducteur a priori a priori ça ces
éléments que j'ai pas exactement à prix
restait le conducteur mais ce qu'on ne
savait pas ce qu'on a su après sékou
conducteur avait un casier qui fait la
police que c'est quelqu'un qui était qui
était vraiment recherché donc ils
l'avaient pas dire ça à tous ses
passagers un bien sûr c'est bien absolu
dire qu'il n'a pas le permis non plus
d'ailleurs entre parenthèses donc du
coup bien ce qui s'est passé et ses
marais 1 comme un gros courageux mobile
et par satellite 8 voilà il prend la
fuite parce qu'il veut pas se faire
arrêter et le pari de ce campus était
recherché par la police il arrive
malheureusement femme a heureusement si
je puis dire parce que je pense à ma
cliente devant un bus et il est coincé
du coup les policiers les trois
policiers en vélo vont vers le véhicule
et l'un d'eux se met du côté passager
prend effectivement au niveau de larmes
commence avec sa crosse a cassé et donc
à l'intérieur de la la c'est faux si la
vision des passagers de hynes qui m'a
donné sa version et donc in s il ya un
gros bruit énorme qui arrivent ils ont
peur et surtout c'est le conducteur qui
a peur et qui repart mais comment d'un
bus marche arrière et leur part ils
arrivent à partir il fait une manoeuvre
il arrive à repartir d'accord à
contourner le bus et il arrive à
repartir alors que là ils aviseront
l'aviron le cas ces accords et que les
policiers voilà un nom interpellé une
première fois voilà une deuxième est la
deuxième fait donc là il ya un deuxième
délit de fuite accord c'est bien qu'on
ait tous ce soir il est maintenant 55
ans n'en dirais que c'est une idée de
faire une affaire qui a fait énormément
quand je vous explique exactement son
sort en vain on va y revenir si dit je
voudrais dire aux téléspectateurs il
20h55 c'est une affaire vraiment effet
énormément dans l'est il faudrait qu'on
est tous les détails cette affaire
puisqu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup de gens
qui ont donné leur avis a beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui ont dit c'est pas
si si c'est passé ça là ce soir les
téléspectateurs veulent voilà l'histoire
est là c'est vrai que voilà on comprend
s'est passé donc la deuxième délit de
fuite voilà c'est lui alors assez
important aussi parce que à l'occasion
de ce deuxième délit de fuite dont il y
avait un policier côté passager passager
passager conducteur et 1 2 et s'avère
qu'au moment justement où il veut fuir
de celui qui est devant s'extrait donc
va du côté ça se protège bien entendu et
heureusement le policier seul sur tech
et donc à ce moment là il est plus du
tout en état de danger ce policier
heureusement il a été sévèrement blessé
on n'a pas des tailles mais apparemment
de parce que n'ayant après il aurait été
blessé ce policier mais il n'est pas été
écrasées il a réussi à passer sur le
côté du coup le véhicule a pu se libérer
partir et c'est à ce moment là qu'ils
ont tiré tiré à vue plus de dix county
de kiel qui couvrent nos comptes d'armes
qu'ils écoutent 10 coups de feu sur les
passagers sur ta sont gardés qu'ils ont
tiré à vue dix coups de feu ce qui veut
dire que il y avait des innocents dedans
des gens qui n'avaient rien à voir que
ce conducteur mais rien à voir et ma
cliente est morte sur le coup avec une
balle dans la tête elle est blessée
également a été blessé au niveau des
doigts cette histoire parce que c'est
vite eu l'idée il ya un instant qu'il
faut tout le monde écoute cette histoire
parce que ça peut être notre soeur va
peut être mais oui voilà une cousine
notre fille surtout c'est pas celle
qu'on a eu une fille voilà et c'est pas
la version vous avez entendu la version
c'est à dire que cette jeune fille s'y
retrouver dans la voiture d'une personne
qui était recherché par la police
n'avait pas son permis et là ça a été un
cauchemar on en décompte pour les
parents on est content quand ils
apprennent ça et c'est vrai que ça ça
doit être vraiment une leçon oui et
c'est incroyable donc là les policiers
tirent dick ou alors il faut savoir
qu'avant qui tirent et dès le départ les
passagers hurlaient arrêtent war on veut
descendre on n'a rien à faire avec toi
laisse nous descendre et donc qui les a
pris en otage il les a pris en otage
donc cibler la famille est en colère
après bien sûr les policiers mais aussi
après ce conducteur rasées soit bien ce
que ce conducteur contre qui et sachez
que demain sur la table du procureur
public il y aura une plainte pour
homicide involontaire contre le
conducteur parce que oui si il n'etait
pas enfui et bien cette petite serait
vivante aujourd'hui 1 et d'ailleurs
heureusement dieu merci les autres
passagers sans vie non parce que l'un
d'eux ait un réflexe de dire mais c'est
vous parce qu'ils ont senti que les que
les policiers étaient étaient avait
décidé il vraiment de tirer et la petite
était devant donc c'était trop tard
voilà trop tard donc elle n'a pas pu se
baisser et malheureusement cette pauvre
victime qui n'a rien à voir cette
affaire s'y retrouver
victime d'une situation histoire d'une
histoire incroyable dramatique surtout
qu'une fois de plus il hurlait tous il
on est tous pour sortir donc y'a aucune
complicité ce que j'ai eue de la presse
est vraiment mais ignoble c'est pour ça
que j'ai répondu à personne parce que
c'est insupportable et je suis heureux
ce soir de la version la vraie version
ce qui s'est passé et bien sûr vous êtes
policier petit cru comprendre sur une
fois plus il n'est pas question de dire
du mal des policiers font un travail
remarquable mais malheureusement il ya
des bavures ça arrive ça arrive et c'est
donc ça je ne sais pas vu et quand vous
alors je vous dis à sylvie je vous donne
le sentiment que j'ai autour de la table
la regarder jouer il va y arriver mais
pour elle ce n'est pas une bavure qui
non mais c'est pas que ce n'est pas une
bavure je ne sais pas voilà je ne sais
pas donc premat déjà dire un terme
bavure déjà moi ça me woerth parce que
je ne sais pas je leur rends ce que vous
dites par rapport à la victime
effectivement et je me mets à votre
place mon fils va en boîte de nuit il
peut rencontrer une copine ou un copain
dont il ne sait rien et puis se
retrouver dans le cas de figure de cette
jeune fille et se retrouver pris au
piège par ce type qui était pour le coup
lui responsable et je je moi je
pardonnez moi mais j'ai envie de blâmer
ce type là et pas de blâmer les flics
parce que je me dis que c'est les
policiers de refus d'obtempérer à un
type dont on apprend après qu'il avait
un casier judiciaire etc et donc ils ont
certainement eu peur un collègue est
blessé donc dans ce cafouillis
incroyable mois la faute je ne la
reporte pas sur les planches dans la vie
de cyril almanach mois à titre
préliminaire on a vous avez toute
l'histoire vous vous dites moi
j'aimerais déjà avoir déjà eu une pensée
pour cette pauvre jeune fille qui est
décédée ça c'est un homme c'est un drame
c'est vrai je pense à sa famille qui
doit être vraiment de maxxium dément je
pense aussi à mes collègues parce que il
faut penser au sentiment de culpabilité
un hôte et une vie ce n'est pas anodin
des noms circulent
déjà c'est compliqué à une pauvre
victime innocente c'est encore pire donc
imaginer que ils vont devoir vivre toute
leur vie avec ça donc c'est vraiment pas
évident quand on exerce cette profession
j'aimerais préciser plus plusieurs
choses j'essaie d'être assez assez
rapide parler de bavure m mais je suis
un peu choqué et je vais répondre en
même temps à l'accusation de monsieur
mélenchon qu'on a vu là qui disait
depuis quand on me tire sur un refus
d'obtempérer mais en fait depuis 2010
est depuis que dans le code de sécurité
intérieure on à l'article l 435 tirer un
alinéa 4 qui précise l'usagé des armes
et notamment que les policiers peuvent
faire usage de leurs armes dans le cas
d'un refus d'obtempérer donc voilà déjà
ce n'est pas une bavure puisqu'ils ont
commis leurs actes dans un cadre légal
ils ont fait ce qu'on leur a appris
maintenant comment on en arrive à la
situation qui a pu se passer mais de
façon simple vous avez comme les très
bien décrit ce conducteur qui refuse le
contrôle pour une ceinture ça aurait pu
être pour n'importe quoi d'autre il
refuse le contrôle il s'en va une
première fois les policiers arrivent à
le rattraper il s'apprête à nouveau à
leur contrôle il est même un de mes
collègues qui casse la vitre pour
pouvoir intervenir
quand on fait une intervention comme
ceux ci ont fait ce qu'on appelle une
triangulation autour du véhicule c'est à
dire que vous avez un collègue qui se
passe près interpellé le conducteur un
autre qui se met en protection et le
troisième sont trois protection
également et au moment où le conducteur
reprend la route entre guillemets au
moment où ils accélèrent où il redémarre
ses instantanés chez le policier la cua
un dixième de secondes pour réfléchir à
ce qui va se passer et dans ce cas là on
ne choisit pas où est ce qu'on va tirer
vous faites un tir réflexe c'est à dire
vous êtes de bouger votre arme
prenez-vous tiré voilà si vous l'avez
des gens m'aiment parce que vous pointez
un policier en fait un véhicule qui fait
refus d'obtempérer vous sortez votre
arme au poing ou ont pointé le
conducteur systématiquement ce qui fait
qu effectivement même si vous êtes un
double action et que la queue de détente
est un peu plus lourde pour appuyer
dessus c'est à dire que vous avez un
recul un peu plus important spontanément
quand le véhicule niveau fonce dessus
vous avez un dixième de seconde pour
savoir qu'est ce que vous allez faire et
là vous pensez à votre vie à celle de
vos collègues et c'est ce qui explique
le tir ce simultanément des trois
policiers et c'est là je vous rejoint
pas le tien des pas simultanée c'est
qu'en fait il n'était plus en situation
de danger donc il y avait plus justement
de légitime défense je vous l'annoncé on
parle du cese si la morale de la moi je
parle pas légitime défense parce que
l'on parle pas du team défense on parle
du code de sécurité intérieure je
connais bien sorti alors c'est l'article
effectivement elle 435 un joker lisez le
on doit faire usage il doit faire usage
de leurs en main de leurs armes de qu'en
cas d'absolue nécessité et de manière
strictement proportionnées l'année de la
vieja ya des plaies encore si je voulais
mettre lisez la lumière est terminée la
corogne à 4 mètres va vous le dire alors
l'année 1 4 les lorsqu'ils ne peuvent
immobiliser autrement que par l'usagé
des armes des véhicules
dont les conducteurs n'obtempère pas à
l'ordre d'arrêt et dont les occupants
sont susceptible de perpétrer dans leur
fuite les atteintes à leur vie ou alors
intégrité physique ou un seul depuis une
voiture folle ça peut créer l'irakien
qui dans la rue main c'est à dire mais
si cette jeune femme de 21 ans qui
n'était qui étaient à bord s'ils
traversent le passage piéton en ce
moment là et qu'elles avaient été
emportés par la fuite du véhicule mais
il aura compté à sa large de la mer
après ce que nous a dit ainsi et matthew
du rêve ici toi qui sais quoi dans ben
évidemment de ma première pensée bien
sûr pour ce
qu'a fait l'erreur de mentir la mauvaise
voiture de quelqu'un qu'elle
connaissions m6 c'est surtout ce qu'il
faut rappeler aussi au jour ne monte pas
en rupture geek et vous ne connaissez
pas c'est tout ce qu'on est aux enfants
oui une fois qu'on a dit cette horreur
pardon m
premier refus deuxième refus là
effectivement je comprends très bien ce
qu'il dit ils se sont mis en
triangulaire comme ça vous vous dites
que le troisième policier qui était
devant a réussi à se dégager j'étais pas
enfin la maintenance était leur vie et
si les laissez passer leur vie si le
laisser partir en paix maintenant
c'était la vie on y arrive d'une voiture
qui était maintenant délit de fuite dans
paris et qu'elle est peut-être sans
risque et d'autres personnes il devait
l'arrêter cette voiture là là je sais
qu'ils ont arrêté la mauvaise que je
vais vous dire c'est que en fait il ya
suffisamment de moyens policiers pour
qu'ils aient des barrages de fait il
suffisait d'appeler de tirer alors qu'il
savait qu'elles des passagers innocents
mais dans le métro et financier
finalement les conducteurs c'est
terrible et injuste si vs qu'il le
savait ça les commandes émanant
évidemment c'est lui qui est qui qui
était un délit de fuite ne savais pas
qu'ils étaient les passagers les
passagers pouvaient pas de complices
avaient toutefois savoir la police alors
qu'elles ont ne tue pas dans ce cas là
on ne tue pas contents alors qu on s y
serait procuré ce qu'ils auraient pas pu
cyril où il me les laisser partir il y
avait des caméras il ya des caméras y
aller où ils avaient peur de mettre ces
cas là on les laisse partir et si c'est
en mètres plus loin vous avez un enfant
qui traverse à qui elle est emportée par
la voiture on fait quoi voilà entre
autres des policiers y avait assez duré
deux heures vous avez assez de barrage
mais n'avait jamais dit m contre
les questions je poserai surprises à la
clé il fallait simplement dans les pneus
de sa voiture a conclu
ni moi n'étions simplement est évident
bien sûr qu'on doit laisser le juge
d'instruction faire son travail
évidemment c'est une première
intervention mais c'est sûrement ce que
je dis simplement c'est que il faut
absolument que les vérifications soient
faites sur la façon donc la lumière une
reconstitution qui doit être effectué
par ce que j'ai entendu des témoins de
cette affaire que personne n'a entendu
que la police a entendu ou va entendre
et ces témoins ont vu de a à z ce qui
s'est passé il ya des mais quand on voit
ce qui s'est passé un jour vous dirais
que j'avais raison parce que y aura une
instruction et l'instruction dire à tous
mais d'autres choses que je ne peux pas
dévoiler mais tout ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que dans cette affaire je
vais déposer une plainte pour homicide
volontaire bien sûr contre les uns et
homicides involontaires contre l'autre
jusqu'alors ce sera au juge
d'instruction de voir ce qu'il en est et
ce sera contre x show dire ce qui est ce
qu ils ont été entendus un les policiers
je vous dire ce qu'il en sort dans un
instant gilbert est votre sentiment oui
moi ce qui m'étonne même c'est que dans
votre témoignage vous reconnaissez vous
même vous l'avez dit que la voiture
après le deuxième refus d'obtempérer et
en mouvement et c'est tout le débat si
vous reconnaissez que la voiture elle de
nouveau à si vous l'avez dit qu'il était
expliqué elle est arrêtée en est arrivé
du été arrêtée et elle repart la
retourner regarder au moment où il ya où
il ya et c'est simplement la vitre
cassée oui le peur la peur des victimes
ans de ce conducteur eut de ce bruit qui
a fait qu'il est reparti mais si elle
repart sa légitime je choisis le mot la
thèse des policiers qui est de dire à
partir du moment et leur part qu'elle
peut nous foncer dessus il ya danger
vous reconnaissez vous même songé à ce
que j'aime bien sûr de béton fourni
n'est rien géré mon avis la faute ce qui
est sûr c'est que la justice et la
lumière de se satisfaire doit être fait
bien sûr il convient de se pas se permet
de faire dans des journaux un tribunal
de cette affaire qu'est-ce que vous avez
c'est ce qu'on doit le savoir qu'est ce
qui vous a gêné lui ce qui m'a gêné
c'est que on ne parle pas de s'être vite
cassé on ne parle pas du fait qu' il ya
une victime qui est décédée
on ne rompt pas donne d'une personne
blessée au jeu je constate qu'on ne pas
une seule fois et un moment d'émotion
cette jeune femme qui était pour rien on
n'a fait que là ça lui est de dire
qu'elle avait un casier ce qui était
faux je ne parle pas effectivement de
cette famille de drames de cette famille
et on considère que circulez ya plus
rien à voir eh bien non parce qu'une
fois plus ça peut arriver nos enfants et
ça c'est dramatique
et ce à raison pour laquelle la lumière
je n'accuse personne je dis juste qu'il
faut vraiment savoir cette affaire ce
qu'il en est et qu'on arrête de faire
effectivement d'état de suppositions et
les pâtes chaudes m 2 dans la presse a
dit que cette jeune fille est bas à
benghazi mais je n'en sais rien moi je
voulais en fait il faut différentiel à
le casual et le delta ge le traitement
des antécédents judiciaires
vous pouvez avoir un taj et ne pas avoir
de casier ça soit vous le savez
maintenant
passé judiciaire et manche chez ces
nombres
l avoir été convoqué par là par la crise
avec quoi s'attache à 15 ans et
trafic de stupéfiants c'est un
fait la fête avec c'est à dire qu'en
fait il n'y a pas eu de suite oui mais
après vous pouvez amener un pion dans le
vieux justifie
pas non plus la pression n'a pas permis
de dire daisy de la presse a dit que la
vague asie c'est pas la panacée langil
chez gerry en cause
c'est dangereux
quand on dit en gros personne
aujourd'hui tu entendu peut très bien
avoir aussi jacques roman crainte à des
jeux et enregistré 1 mais s'est offert
ses toiles est horrible pour la famille
ça mais c'est d'entendre des chansons
génétique mais quand même et dans votre
discours c'est que vous parliez tout à
l'heure de bavures en ayant quand même
la parfaite connaissance du code de
sécurité intérieure l'enfant
non des cdc et s'efforcer maira l'aller
ce n'est pas une bavure même si c'est
triste et dramatique on ne savait pas à
tirer à vue sur une voiture à des
enfants qui a renversé devant et qui
aurait pu être fauchés qu'est ce que
c'est ça alors alors là vous offrez le
bonnet une facture des suppositions mais
en 2010 c'est ce qu'il faut être plus ce
conducteur ne ne pouvait pas été une rue
extrêmement étroite ne pouvais pas
rouler comme un malade ça n'existait pas
c'est quoi jardiner ou déroulé à sens
absolument et au détriment des passagers
au détriment de la sotra et finalement
des passagers qui était en danger s'est
amené avec eux l'a7 pacha de cette
passagère a été autant victime que les
eaux de m il faut combien il faut
combien de refus d'obtempérer avec des
sens uniques en plus question que tout
d'un coup on puisse considérer
véritablement qui est en danger mais il
en est au troisième elle a arrêté deux
fois déjà je ne vous laisserai
interviennent savez je dis simplement
qu'une fois que vous comme moi on ne
sait pas ce qui s'est passé il faut
impérativement que nous écrire et mettre
bavure non mais savoir ce s'est passé au
nez haut niveau j'ai dit redouter du tir
à quel moment exactement quels en sont
les témoins les bavures j'ai entendu
on l'espère toutefois le rapport aux
témoins déjà entendus
elle a désiré moi j'ai des
supers en toi simplement pour dire
qu'aujourd'hui on a une jeune femme qui
est décédée qu' il ya un monsieur
effectivement un homme qui
à cause c'est à cause de lui finalement
que toutes ces tâches sur ce fameux
conducteur mais ça c'est sûr c'est que
maintenant c'est lui qui doit relater
pas ma cliente qui est victime qui est
décédée et il faut que nous ayons tous
une pensée pour d'autres cette famille
va bien en premier jamais pensé en même
temps pour la jeune femme rue de rivoli
qui a été tuée par un chauffard qui
était justement en travail fille et qui
n'a pas été arrêté par les policiers oui
ok excusez moi là on a dépensé pour les
deux rives et pour les deux très bien je
suis pleinement d'accord et moi je suis
une fée plus je ne suis pas contre les
policiers bien évidemment c'est ça la
règle du célibat n'est
plus maître là votre vos démarches et
quand même de mettre en l'accusation va
donner moi la police vous considérez que
ils ont mal agi en faisant ce tir et je
me demande moi comme il faudra mettre
deux flics dans des cercueils pour que
au soir à mesure de juger ses fonctions
alors à mes 9 fini juste mesure c'est
épouvantable on est tous d'accord c'est
affreux ce qui s'est passé mais ils sont
aujourd'hui on à la police que les gens
n'ont plus peur de la police que les
gens quand on les arrête ne s'arrête pas
une fois deux fois trois fois et étirent
malheureusement quand on a rien à te
reprocher ou m on se bat ya là dessus et
c'est ça le drame et les stades rappelez
vous allez être un client et vous avez
raison dans votre
milieu
le full tout ça c'est que si les gens
s'arrêtent même si donc voilà oui si les
gens s'arrêtaient il s'en est pas la
connaissance de
l'action de m noachovitch elle est pour
rien non mais on ne peut offrir
[Musique]
monsieur désert que 6e en vie vous avez
dit quelque chose de terrible terrible
vous avez dit vous avez cherché les
antécédents judiciaires de la cliente de
madame je vous signale et vous le savez
très bien ce que vous avez dit c'est
terrible c'est très pervers et ça ça n'a
rien à voir
ça montre absolument la différence avec
le pas et ses moyens de finir je
voudrais casile judiciaire antécédents
judiciaires j'ai donc c'était difficile
mathieu qui demandait pourquoi donc dans
l'est
je veux dire que la kapisa c'est une
erreur a n'a pas de casier judiciaire
elle avait dix ans ici dont
a été entendu deux fois sur des voies
actuelles étaient entendus et ça n'a
rien à voir avec quoi là l'histoire
réponse un drame voilà quoi qu'il arrive
même si la vie à katiola
bah oui jamais eu c'est un drive mieux
avoir avec ses
plus de salir les les policiers ni quoi
que ce soit je suis simplement que la
lumière doit cesser sa bien sûr en soit
si tu ne m'avais en soit en ce sens
qu'il ya il ya des morts une passagère
qui n'est bien en même temps et ce n'est
faire une bavure survient
alors on va le dire c'est un drame et la
comédie drame doivent être élucidées oui
c'est pour ça qu'une nouvelle va être
déposée pour que toute la lumière soit
faite mais si
tu veux que matisse et pardon m ça m'a
aussi vous entendre sur quelque chose
qui est très important parmi les
victimes en parts dont juste la coque ce
policier c'est un drame mais si oui à
une bavure et j'aimerais vous entendre
aussi sur quelque chose qui est qu' il
faut absolument s'arrêter le refus
c'est
tout
sylviane et sylvie martel et désignait
les pépites et lui elle est dépité par
ce diagnostic et moi
pour mes lecteurs bien sûr mais si tu
perds j'aimerais rappeler si vous me le
permettez syrie que c'est que les
policiers sont de plus en plus victimes
d'agressions oui ont de plus en plus
victimes de véhicules maladie ça si tu
sais quand même on est
tous d'accord en roulements sauf mais ce
drame doit être doigt puis jamais arrivé
et pour cela il faut une enquête
spéciale elle va s'arrêter pour cela
aussi il faut que vont nous aider à
être entendus soit entendu pour que
toute la lumière soit faite sur ce
dossier vraiment la famille reste
convaincue et c'est normal veut savoir
ce qui s'est passé et c'est normal tout
à fait là c'est pas perdu j'ai une
pensée pour ces postes et palace avec le
court ce soir c'est ça un drame parce
qu'évidemment on est tous d'accord ni
sur les montants de ces ça on est tous
d'accord pour dire qu'ils allaient y est
pour rien la fille elle s'en allait en
fait avait perdu la vie parce qu'elle
est sortie d'une fête donc oui comme ça
bêtement médecin elle a accepté
l'invitation ryad les années si on
retourne des années en arrière la plaie
les policiers se font tirer dessus dans
la rue délibérément bévue pape et on
respecte plus la police et le refus
d'obtempérer une fois deux fois envie
d'être du côté de la police et d'un
autre côté tu te dis est-ce que c'est
pas disproportionnée 10 coups de feu
avec des innocents dans une voiture tu
dit je pense aux collègues qui compte
irait mais c'est avec la lumière et
faire la loi c'est tout bon d'accord moi
les gars je suis pour le cadre légal et
je dis toujours s'il ne faut pas faire
n'importe quoi si tu te mets dans une
situation comme ça tu dois t'arrêter tu
t'arrêtes mais là il ya des innocents
dans la voiture qui le
suis d'accord et j'ai et je suis
d'accord aussi sur les faits s'ouvriront
la voiture elle part ça peut taper un
gamin cas rien à voir là dedans il peut
perdre le contrôle de deux oui dur taper
un arrêt de bus il peut arriver plein de
choses juste maintenant ce qu'il faut
dire c'est ce que série made in ne monte
pas avec des inconnus mais est
maintenant arrêter les refus
d'obtempérer pour des défauts de permis
des conneries board et des photos
qu'elle a drainé galea falloir comme le
revoir parce que si c'est ça c'est le
sort de ces scrutins j'entends mes
amendes et à des choses à voir également
donné et là c'est dix fois portionné
c'est la loi prévoit que en cas de
disproportion il ya sanction donc ça
c'est le juge d'instruction qui le verra